Hey guys. Pete here. Today I'm gonna do a
follow-up to my Dark (Netflix)season 3 official
trailer breakdown from a couple of days
ago. There were some things I wanted to
clarify from that, and we also got a
bunch of new official promo photos
yesterday that I want to talk about. This
video will contain spoilers from
everything that's happened in the first
two seasons of Dark and everything that
is out there on the Internet. If you're
spoiler sensitive this video probably
isn't for you, but at the same time I
haven't seen anything that gives away
the central mysteries yet. from what I've
seen on Reddit there are reviews from
journalists that have seen the entire
season starting to show up. I haven't
done a deep dive into those yet, but I
will after I finish this video because
I've learned from having a channel that
if there's information out there someone
will post it in the comments on my
videos and if I'm gonna be spoiled I'm
gonna do it from the source.
so you may want to use caution when
reading through the comments and with
that let's jump into it. first things
first
in my trailer breakdown I missed that
there were multiple older women's voices
in the voiceover. several native German
speakers pointed out in the comments
that one of those voices was older
Claudia. the trailer inside the Netflix
client has different subtitles where
those voices are marked as woman 1
through 4. this is who I think they are:
Woman 1 says, "everything repeats itself
because no one of us is ready to let go."
later she says, "I want that your journey
finally finds an end," and even later, "and
so everything starts from the beginning."
this is almost certainly Eve since we
first hear this voice in the room that
looks like it's her lair and later while
she's standing in front of the painting
with the trio. Woman number 2 only has
one line where she says, "I finally want
to know the truth." I've read that this is
probably the actress that plays Stranger
aged alt Martha and that sounds like a
good guest to me. skipping to Woman 4
she's the one who says, "a world without
you isn't that what you wanted?" and this
is who they're saying is older Claudia
speaking. it makes sense but we don't
know where the voiceover is coming from
since we don't see her in the trailer.
Woman 3 delivers the line, "the apocalypse
in your world is
also happening in ours." I thought this
sounded familiar and thought it might be
Charlotte. apparently though it's
Katharina and there's a lot of stuff
related to her I want to talk about.
while I was working on my trailer video
this post showed up on reddit. it makes a
good case that katharina is the person
getting bludgeoned in this scene based
on the clothing. what's wild about that
is the working assumption is that this
character is Helene Albers who is
Katharina's own mother. I talked about this
theory in my the "End is the Beginning"
video so I won't go into it again here
but man that's crazy that she's likely
going to be killed by her mother.
yesterday Dark opened six new official
Instagram accounts. five related to the
time periods we've already seen in the
show and one related to the alt world in
2019. they're all interesting and you
should check them out individually and
there's even some new photos from the
upcoming season mixed in there. and one
of those we get a look at Katharina in
1987 inside the high school we see
teenage Hannah in the hallway near her
and that Katharina is carrying a missing
poster with Mikkel on it this is
somewhat confusing the poster says Kahnwhald
instead of Neilson indicating
that Mikkel has time traveled and has
been taken in by Ines. it has the same
photo that she gave to Egon which he
later showed Ulrich. to this point we
haven't heard anything about Mikkel
going missing after being adopted but
everything else seems consistent with
the prime world. young Hannah and the
hallway look the same and for me this
is all confirmation that she's in prime
Winden. what's going on with the missing
poster is a mystery at this point. this
photo was actually taken down from the
Instagram account and I'm wondering if
the information on the posters has
something to do with that. a popular
theory has been that Katharina would
travel to the alt world because of the
lights we see around her during the
apocalypse while she's opening the door
in the passage. there are posts out there
saying this photo is evidence of
that but I don't see it. in the alt world
this scene that I wasn't sure about in
the room that was Michael's studio turned
out to be alt mikkel and alt Katharina.
kind of fitting that his bedroom
is in that room it was a mystery whether
an alt Mikkel existed but this Nielsen
family photo they posted on the
alt-world
Instagram account seems to confirm that.
in that they all look pretty happy
compared to other shots we've seen of
them and it looks like Ulrich has been
torn out. to me this hints that alt Martha
will be affected by her parents
splitting apart and that alt Ulrich could
literally be out of the picture.
one last Katharina thing is that she may
actually be the person we saw with the
head wrap in the desert. this photo was
in the behind the scenes photos and was
captioned with the question "a new
character?" I wasn't able to tell who it
was at the time - I really just kind of
wrote it off but after the trailer came
out the debate started back up. the two
most popular choices were Katharina or
adult Michael and since it looks like a
woman I believe the people guessing
Katharina are correct. another question I
had from the trailer that's been
answered definitively is the black
notebook we saw on Eve's desk. I didn't
remember seeing it but it turns out this
was the book that Bernd Doppler gave
Claudia with the data about the power
plant incident in 1986 why it's.
important to Eve and why she has it with
the other artifacts is still a mystery
it makes me wonder if those three items
are from the prime world and maybe have
been brought to her but we'll have to
wait and see. out of the other new photos
they released there's one of alt Woller
and alt Charlotte. Woller has no eye
injury but he's missing an arm in the
alt world. I guess he can't catch a break
anywhere. there's also a shot of Martha
outside the school in the yellow
raincoat and this made me think of
something I hadn't really talked about
in my previous videos. we spent a lot of
time wondering about alt Martha and where
she was taking Jonas and about Eve. seeing
that she wears the yellow raincoat and
functions in the same sort of role as
Jonas in her world means that we'll
likely see her in all the same phases of
her development. we were introduced to
her as a traveler that can move between
worlds but the version of her in the
raincoat probably has no idea about time travel
yet. the alt Martha that saves Jonas from
the apocalypse has shorter hair and at
different times we see her with an
injury to her face. there may even be a
mark on her neck visible in this shot
when we see her in the distant past as
was pointed out to me on Twitter. this
tells me that this one is like young
Jonas after he's been traveling. so for
an example this shot of Martha running
away from the bunker would be in her
earlier timeline. she will have
experienced all of this stuff before she
becomes the person who saved him at the
end of season 2. I mentioned before that
one of the women's voices we hear is
likely her at the stranger's age so we
have every reason to believe that her
progression to Eve will mirror Jonas's
to Adam and we're likely to see a good
bit of it. obviously some of the details
will be different. the thing that was
confusing to me at first was in the
trailer scenes the all-world hadn't
experienced the apocalypse yet but I
guess we might be able to explain that
away if the orb machine can travel to
any day just like the god particle twin
does. it makes sense if it is the most
evolved time machine and I'm guessing
that maybe the alt Martha that saves him
takes him back before the apocalypse
happens where he then meets the one in
the raincoat. that would line things up
with him being there prior to their
apocalypse and would free up the older
version of her to go back in time where
we see her with Sic Mundus. either way
it seems like we'll be spending more
time with Martha which could mean that we
spend less time with other characters.
another photo we see in the new accounts
is this photo of an Ouroboros bracelet
from 1954. this isn't an artifact I
remember seeing previously but we did
see this imagery inside the caves. Hannah
is the biggest question mark for this
time period so this may be related to
her story. on the account for 2053 this
photo of the god particle showed up
which might be interesting. in the
trailer we had several scenes with Adam
where it looked like he was activating
the black blob as part of his plan. of
course it looked different than it had
in the past in that instead of
stabilizing it opened up and then spun
violently collapsing on itself. if this
photo puts those scenes
2053 that's interesting in relation to
the desert looking scenes we see. to me
it looks like Adam goes into the future
after the apocalypse and does something
in 2053 that changes the world making
it the desertified landscape we see
putting those scenes in 2086. which makes
sense in that we knew we were probably
going to visit 1888 and in turn expand
33 years into the future
the last photo to talk about is this
shot from the 2020 page
it's a Peter and Elisabeth post
apocalypse which isn't surprising since
we knew they would survive in the bunker
it could be interesting in relation to
the timeline though in the prime world
it looks like we will pick up shortly
after the event that happened at the
power plant and that could mean that
most of the events across timelines will
happen in say a month or a couple
months after June 27th and for example
that could tell us that Hannah will be in
1954 for a few months or Katharina will
be in 1987 for a few months or however
long is between the event and Peter
standing here talking to these people
who are responding to the disaster. one
other thing I didn't notice in the
trailer that was pointed out was that in
the very beginning when we see the
explosion in the Kahnwald house we don't
see the yellow light indicating that
Martha is saving Jonas that would make
sense in the alt world since there is no
Jonas to save it happens the other way
around which we've seen Jonas saves alt
Martha the only thing that's kind of
interesting about this though is that it
seems like everything is kind of
mirrored in the backgrounds in the alt
world and we even saw a photo of the Kahnwald house being mirrored but in the
trailer they didn't actually change that
so make what you will out of that and
finally there have been a lot of
questions about this infinity symbol and
this new mirrored family tree one of the
theories I see brought up a lot is that
perhaps Adam and Eve have a child and
that their child is the beginning of
everything that doesn't really make a
lot of sense to me because of the
mirrored nature of these branching
family trees in order to make that work
you
have to make it like so that Agnes or
her father was actually twins one went
to the One World and one went to the
other world
to me the infinity symbol is likely just
a representation of the two timelines
splitting I don't know what that means I
don't really have a great theory about
what that is but as we see and
everything that we've seen so far the
people in the alt world are different
versions it's not the same person doing
the same thing in two different worlds
so this idea that there's one child or
one person who is the start of the split
of the timelines doesn't really make a
lot of sense to me and really this whole
layout that they showed us in the
trailer confuses me more than anything
else I'm curious to see what this whole
layout looks like and what it is but I
don't see anything that's solving the
mysteries of the dark universe for me by
looking at this and with that I think I
will end this video here let me know
what you think of the new photos that
was pretty cool how they dropped all
those accounts let me know if there's
anything else I missed from the trailer
let me know what theories do you think
are the most interesting do you get the
same sense that I do that season 3 will
be focused much more on alt Martha and
what other questions do you have please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already thanks for watching I'll talk to
you soon